>> Larry: OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
WELL-- I MEAN, IT SEEMS UNCLEAR
IF THIS IS A HATE CRIME OR JUST
ARSON OR ACCIDENTS OR SOME WEIRD
COSMIC COINCIDENCE, OR IF
LIGHTNING JUST HATE BLACK
PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
SERIOUSLY, IT WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE OF THE "NIGHTLY
SHOW" TO SAY ANYTHING WITHOUT
ALL THE FACTS.
HERE TO HELP US IS FIRE TRUTHER
SANTANA CRIMSEY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WELCOME-- WELCOME TO THE SHOW,
SANTANA.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, LARRY.
>> Larry: OH, NO PROBLEM, NO
PROBLEM.
WHERE ARE YOU RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M AT A FIRE DEPARTMENT IN
JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI, JUST
MAKING SURE THESE WHITE
FIREFIGHTERS HOP TO IT AS SOON
AS THE NEXT BLACK CHURCH STARTS
BURNING.
>> Larry: OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
OH, YOU EXPECT MORE?
>> COME ON, BROTHER.
WAKE UP.
OF COURSE, I EXPECT MORE.
THIS IS THE A WAVE OF HATE
CRIMES.
>> Larry: HOLD ON NOW,
SANTANA.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE
CONCERNED BUT THE FACT IS SOME
OF THESE FIRES ARE NOT HATE
CRIMES.
THAT CHURCH IN FLORIDA LIKELY
CAUGHT FIRE AFTER A TREE FELL ON
A POWER LEAN.
>> LARRY, THAT WAS AN OBVIOUS
FALSE FLAG.
COME ON.
YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S A WHITE
MAN DEVIOUS ENOUGH TO CUT DOWN A
TREE ON SOME POWER LINES?
COME ON, MAN!
WHITE FOLKS HAVE BEEN SECRETLY
CHOPPING DOWN TREES SINCE GEORGE
WASHINGTON DID IT.
OPEN YOUR EYES!
>> Larry: I KNOW, ALL RIGHT.
>> WHERE YOU AT?
>> Larry: ANOTHER SANTANA, I
KNOW.
WHAT ABOUT THE STATISTIC, A 2013
STUDY FOUND 1780 FIRES OCCURRED
AT A VARIETY OF CHURCHES IN ONLY
FOUR YEARS, AND ONLY 16%
INVOLVED ARSON.
SOME OF THESE BUILDINGS ARE
OLD AND FULL OF BAD WIRING.
>> LARRY, AGAIN, YOU'RE BEING
NAIVE, BROTHER. YOU DON'T THINK
THERE'S A WHITE MAN DEVIOUS
ENOUGH TO JOIN THE ELECTRICIANS
UNION AND FILL BLACK CHURCHES
WITH FAULTY WIRING.
COME ON, MAN!
COME ON!
>> Larry: IT SOUND--
>> LARRY, WHITE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FOOLING WITH ELECTRICITY SINCE
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
THAT PART OF IT IS TRUE.
I CAN'T MAKE BLANKET STATEMENTS.
IF I START MAKING RACIAL
ACCUSATIONS THAT AREN'T TRUE,
PEOPLE MIGHT LOSE FAITH IN ME.
WHAT IF MY SHOW GOT CANCELED?
>> AND YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THAT,
LARRY?
>> SUSPICIOUS ABOUT WHAT?
>> YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S A
WHITE MAN OUT THERE DEVIOUS
ENOUGH TO WORK HIS WAY UP TO A
TELEVISION STATION IN ORDER TO
GIVE YOU-- IN ORDER TO GIVE A
BROTHER A LATE NIGHT SHOW SO HE
CAN CANCEL IT?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT?
IT'S A CONSPIRACY
COME ON MAN. "WE TRIED BLACK
SHOWS, IT DIDN'T WORK OUT"
YOU KNOW HOW IT GOES.
>> Larry: NOW I AGREE WITH
YOU!
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO AGREE ON
THAT!
SANTANA CRIMSEY, EVERYBODY.